on topics and to start off we have
photos which was from A&M at guitar and
cryptography and channel thank you Chris
good morning thanks to Chris Danielle
and Daniela for the invitation and
thanks for the audience for being here
on Friday morning so let me start by
this table I had some fun this week
making the table it was not here two
weeks ago so I'm trying to compare
coding theory and cryptography so let's
say any larger fields the information
theory and computer science and what are
the different parameters we use and the
different criteria so I'm not going to
comment everything in the table some
some elements are maybe controversial
but let's say this is the red and the
blue and the red
first item about the probability of
error so you know in cryptography you
would like Bob to to decrypt with zero
error probability now we don't have zero
error probability in in channel coding
there is no zero error rate this doesn't
exist and it means immediately this is
going to be a bottleneck for
cryptography I mean the place where you
transmit digital information or the
place where you store digital
information we cannot have 10 to minus
120 this is impossible so this is a kind
of bottleneck so the numbers I put here
this is for voice 10 to minus 6 this is
for data 10 to minus 9 let's say
high-definition video 10 to minus 15 and
below let's say 10 to minus 20 this is
for fiber-optic communications but we
never have below that and we don't try
to do it in practice now of course in
theory and this is what in my main
theorem I'm going to prove today I would
like this error probability to vanish to
go to 0 now the dimensions 8,000 seems
reasonable so maybe twice this sometimes
16,000 the same in in practical
applications today I will show you 1
million we can do 2 million
and of course when we do analysis we can
let the dimension go to infinity and we
do analysis in both fields is the same
okay finally a point signal-to-noise
ratio it's not obvious in information
theory we have we take into account the
energy of a constellation so when we
have a lattice sometimes we don't deal
with the lattice as an infinite
constellation we carve a finite
constellation and the finite
confirmation has a finite second order
moment so we call this energy now there
is something similar in a morphic
encryption the this threshold of the the
maximum noise
you should have after many operations in
a morphic encryption so this is may be
similar to some signal-to-noise ratio
but I'm not sure about it if because we
don't have the notion of finish in in
cryptography okay so I'm trying to be
too open for the audience are in
computer science and cryptography leão
if you have a question don't do not
hesitate either precaution it by
superlattice it's gonna be indeed but
but the queue is is large yeah you see I
mean if we take the example of Wi-Fi we
never go beyond 256 points in Wi-Fi so
they okay in DSL but DSL is over because
we replaced by optical fiber we can go
up to 32,000 points but there is no no
constellation bigger than this in
practice again in theory we can let the
number of points today I'm going to deal
only with lattices infinite number of
points any consolation okay so so this
is the model huh yes
comments luckily this signal-to-noise
ratio yes so I I feel that the main
difference between the two between this
notion between channel coding versus
cryptography is that in coding Theory
you know the noise is given by nature
and in some sense we don't want the
noise but you know you actually
artificially adding the noise so in some
sense it's it's by nature but also we
have interference from other users in
communication so we have two types of of
noise in cryptography yeah it's it's
it's it's not the same want to add noise
yeah but this is the friendly noise for
the mchale is like crypto systems I
agree but here I'm talking probably
about the noise generated when you when
you do the encryption each time is a
more efficient via the noise level is
increasing and then at one point it's
not yeah so I'm I mean if you have other
suggestions to improve this table please
do not hesitate send me an email we can
I'm sure I mean this tables I wrote it
this week and every day I was modifying
a little bit having some comments if you
have further comments please do not
hesitate send me an email
okay so this is the main the main model
a really simplified model for
information transmission using lattices
the encoding is not necessarily via a
generator matrix for the lattice it can
be done differently but here I want it
just to simplify so that the information
is in Zed and then starting since a
lattice is that the module in this case
I'm from Z I create X the lattice point
this is the simplest channel model
Gaussian noise additive white Gaussian
noise Y it means the components of the
noise are iid are independent mainly but
we assume they are iid
and zero Sigma square so the this Sigma
square I'm going to use it till the end
of my so this is the variance of the
noise of the additive noise on our
channel and then the decoder is here so
so this is simply why I'm saying
information transmission because the
idea is once you get X here at the
decoder output the idea is to get back
to Z from from X now we can define two
different probability of error so the
first probity of error is the profit of
error per point per lattice point now we
like encoding sometimes we call it word
error probability where the rate because
a codeword of lattice point is the same
vocabulary and then we can also talk
about the error probability per
coordinate per lattice coordinate so
this is when X is different from X I hat
okay now today in the demo I'm going to
show your symbol error rate
I mean probability of error per
coordinate at the end of my talk and the
demo however in my proofs I'm only going
to talk about the probability of error
per point in our books okay yes
now in in between coats in modern I
don't like the word modern but we are
using it in my title I mean what is
modern today in 10 years maybe it's not
modern anymore so in modern channel
coding we use iterative decoding
additive decoding is is locally oriented
means you decode the symbol and the
neighborhood of the symbol in the code
there is no global view it's not like
what we call maximum likelihood decoder
or a closest point decoder so in fact
the iterative decoding of the lattice is
going to decode the lattice coordinate
one by one so what is that's why at the
end I get the what we call the a PP the
a posteriori probability of each lattice
coordinate and depending on that
probability we decide what is the value
of the lattice coordinate so then the
ser is one of the parameters we use now
of course usually when the ser is I will
show you when the ser is going down the
wer is also is vanishing now in some
applications you may still have a big
block let's say a lattice and dimension
10,000 but only one coordinate is is
erroneous in that case what we do in
coding if I have an LDPC code and I have
to erroneous bits I plug a BCH code on
top of the LDPC code so here it's like
if the lattice is not enough you put an
extra layer of correction of error
correction to help the lattice okay so
but I will show you later at the end of
the talk okay right now I would like you
just to be sure that all of you
understand this very simple model and
then the main theorem I'm going to prove
is about this simple model so I'm not
going to consider finite consolation no
I'm sorry I have only one hour I cannot
talk about Voronoi constellations so
this is how we do the shaping in these
lattices we take a sub lattice so with
Voronoi cell is bigger and then we do
the shaping using Voronoi constellations
you are not we were going to talk about
finite only infinite constellations so
many questions I'm asking three
questions I'll try to transfer the three
questions first one what is the maximal
Sigma square such that I have a
vanishing error probability
of course you normalize the the
fundamental volume of the of the lattice
let's say volume is one second question
can we build the family of lattices that
can achieve this Sigma square okay fine
now you know it's like Shannon random
coding there exists 1948 we have good
codes but how to build them so this is
in fact here I'm asking probably there
are lattices to achieve the Sigma max I
will call it Sigma max can we build them
and then it's not enough can we decode
these lattices it's the noise variance
on the yeah so this is here we are in n
dimensions so this is a vector a noise
vector in RM and each noise coordinate
is n 0 Sigma square and I assume they
are iid so the idea is what is the
maximum value of the noise such that you
will be able to decode with the
vanishing error probability when n goes
to infinity so these are the three
questions I'll try to give you proofs
and try I will give the idea but you
have to be patient because we have many
lemmas before reaching the main theory
okay I have also some nice coloring and
some nice figures let's see I try in my
best first let me let me talk about
algebraic construction of lattices and
now I'm going to build these lattices
before giving you these Sigma max so I
will talk about the Sigma max it's
coming but first I'm going to talk about
building good lattices out of error
correcting codes so this was suggested
in 1971 by Li Chen Sloane
it's called construction a so what do
you do in fact you look at p ZN p that n
has p 2n cassettes inside ZN you select
some of those cassettes how many P 2 K
how do you select P 2 K using the error
correcting code see I call it si
it is of length n the same dimension as
the lattice K is the dimension of C as a
subspace of F P - n ok so we say
dimension lengths we should not mix
between because the dimension of the
lattice is the length of the code but
the dimension of the code is K okay so
this is how we do it now I'm writing it
like this
this is a simple formula that works well
with Z now you have to be careful why
because C
she lives in FP so it means you have to
do some natural embedding from FP to Z
that that's very easy for Z of course
you can change the drink if you'd like
you can do Gaussian integers Isis time
integers quaternions I call the end and
even we saw it also this week we can use
number fields and the ring of integers
the number field again when you are here
you have to be careful you should put
the oume morphism going from from the
finite fields into the ring okay you
cannot write it like this but I'm
writing the equation of lambda like this
just for simplicity okay now how can you
see this this construction a formula so
look at the code this is AP area code so
imagine a cube in dimension N and the
side of the cube is P and then some
points of the code are inside that cube
and then what do you do with the cube
you move the cube in all direction by P
you pave the space you get a lattice so
this is how geometrically you can you
can see construction a formula okay and
of course near the origin the lattice
will get the same properties as the code
itself so if you know about how the
reading distance of the lattice is
distributed around the origin in fact
it's the same as the distribution of the
code now this data series is the same
around the origin up to P minus 1 over 2
ok now if if we consider the number
fields of course you have to put this
Phi so the formula is like this I put
Phi of C what is Phi Phi is going from
FP FP into lambda ok so
the notation is the same Oh is the big
ol is the ring of integers in K in the
number field
so here what do we do we take the rank
of integers okay is similar to Z and
then we apply canonical embedding to get
a lattice now what did we do in
construction a in said we are using PZ
what is PZ in fact it's an ideal of Z we
do the same in number field we take an
ideal I we apply Sigma 2 are you we get
a lambda I so lambda I is the equivalent
of PZ if you want and okay is the
equivalent of Z and then you have
similar construction a so this is the PZ
lambda I and here I have to embed FP
into okay and this is an example with P
equal 11 okay P equal 11 if you so this
is a lattice lambda okay from Q square
root of five and if I take this three
four shells of the lattice here I have
two points here I have four and here I
have also one two four and and the
origin you get 11 points this in fact
this is FP this is FP and in the plane
and then the blue points you see here
this is the equivalent of peas dead this
is the ideal and then what does it mean
making construction a it means the error
correcting code will choose points just
from here among the 11 points in f11 and
then the plus ideal raise to M will move
these points everywhere to get the whole
lattice the same as was dead okay fine
now this is I wanted to show you this
slide this is a slide I did five years
ago but I I modified I added this week I
added this this line so I'm trying to
gather all possible construction of
eight just to show you that really
algebraic constructions are are
wonderful and and so so rich
of course here this is e 8 I'm not going
to do a demo is 8 in dimension 8 this is
too small however this is one of the
most beautiful lattices 8 and of course
lambda 24 delete net is so what you see
here this is construction a
from the extended Hamming code eight for
four binary P equal to 2 but my talk
today is not about binary construction
it's it's non Pieri and I'm going to let
P go to infinity this is the master
construction using two error correcting
codes this is called construction B it's
not construction a and here it's over
the Gaussian integers Z of I you can
also do over the ISIS on integers over
quaternions
and then of course if you take the icons
in its directly eight equal to i columns
and here what I showed you if you take
the ideal this is a special ideal in
fact you have to take five okay the
principle ideal you factorize that ideal
and you get this one so these are these
are the two okay generators and this is
a cyclotomic field 20 you do Sigma R you
get eh no need for construction a there
is no construction a it's just you take
this cyclotomic field you get eight yeah
so this is the beauty of algebraic
constructions now of course today we
want to let n go to infinity
unfortunately it will not be as
beautiful as eight so but it will be
beautiful in terms of graph theory I'm
going to use a lot the graph description
of the code in inside the lattice okay
now back to construction a this is the
generator matrix of the lattice when you
use construction a okay please remember
construction a just remember this lambda
is a apiary code you you embed directly
into Z plus P Z then okay and K over N
is what we call the coding rate of this
code okay so the generator matrix of
lambda after construction a is very
simple in fact what you see here is the
generator matrix of the code and then
you add the missing dimensions P times
the identity matrix n minus K so now do
I need this matrix probably no because
today in my 1 million demo I'm not going
to
the matrix of 1 million times 1 million
no yeah but this is a way if you need it
for small dimensions this is how you get
from the code to the lattice in terms of
generator matrix now of course we can we
have the from the motel volume of the
lattice this is obvious because P to n
is the volume of pz m and because you
are translating by p2k different
translates so you P to n divided by P 2
K you get the fundamental volume and
then we have a simple lower bound upper
bound for the Euclidean distance minimum
euclidian distance of the lattice of
course it cannot exceed P Square why
because P said piece at N is a sub
lattice so so this is what I showed you
here I showed you that piece that n is
inside our construction a lambda and
lambda is inside the okay so it means if
P is small you make lambda weak
you cannot keep P finite I cannot
achieve the limit Sigma max by keeping p
finite i need to let p increase now by
how much if you look at the literature
and the literature p increases as n 2
lambda and lambda at least half and most
of the time greater than 1 so 1 SI
literature this who started analyzing
this andrea la liga in 1997 and then
further 2004 arrays and zamir in tel
aviv also they did it so in all these
analysis it was n 2 lambda P was n 2
lambda what I'm going to show you today
I'm going to break that I'm going to do
P polyrhythmic
log n raised to a and then we have a
condition on a so I have a much smaller
P then then what we were doing in the
literature before ok so what else I can
say and then of course the squared
minimum distance normalized by the
volume volume 2 to n this is what we
call fundamental gain of the lattice by
abuse of terminology I I call it the air
might constant of the lattice so this is
related to the packing density of the
lattice it's not very important today I
will be able to achieve
Sigma max without having the best
packing density the best termite
constant so so this is the the Sigma max
I'm announcing the Sigma max without the
proof of Sigma max I will prove how to
achieve so this was discovered in 1994
but in fact there are two other rolls of
paper or more recent papers talking
about the same the same Sigma max with
different vocabulary so in fact it's 1
over 2 pi e this is how what you should
remember 1 over 2 pi e what is funny
this number 1 over 2 pi e it's also if
you compute the second order moment of a
spear in n dimension when you let n go
to infinity you get also the 1 over 2 pi
e so in some way it's also related
miracle to shaping but I'm not talking
about shaping today and of course if the
volume is not 1 you scale by V 2 to M so
what is this Sigma max if in fact this
if and only if so it means if if Sigma
square is greater than this quantity
whatever you do whatever is the lattice
whatever is your decoder the probability
of error will not vanish and then if
Sigma squared is less than Sigma max
there exists the family of lattices
lambda N and going to infinity such that
the probability of error is vanishing
okay now since we know the fundamental
volume of the construction a I plug it
here so this is our Sigma max of
construction a and then I would like to
approach the Sigma max I put some Delta
so we're going to use Sigma square
equals Sigma x 1 minus Delta square so
the Delta is on Sigma and then I would
like to to prove in my construction that
the probability of error will vanish for
any Delta greater than 0 yes
[Music]
yes but it's not constructive we don't
know how yeah I'm just taking the
formula of V the fundamental value of
the volume of the Voronoi cell from
construction a and plugging it here they
will this is improving today and this is
my main theory yeah but but I'm using a
special code I'm using a very simple
code that I can also decode again if you
put a random code you're going yeah so
this was already proven in 1997 as I
said by law Nagar if you put a random
code where the parity check matrix is
danced you're going to achieve this
limit Polti rev limit but how do you do
code the random code
I don't know how do you go to know so
today I'm going to show you a
low-density code now be careful when I
say low-density
it's about this parsecity of the parity
check matrix however the the packing
density of the lattice can be very good
if if I say low-density its low-density
about H not about the lattice and then
this code I can decode in practice and
it will reach Sigma max using
construction a
our is the yes as I said K over N the
coding rate so yeah the choice of R is
important why because from this simple
bound you can see that the air might
constant is upper bounded by P to R it's
like if you take the coding rate too
small you're making the might constant
bad going down now what will happen to
main to the main theorem I will show P
is going to be log n raised to a and a
to R is greater than 1 so we're going to
have a behavior where the the air might
cancer is increasing as log n this is
not the best the best is n so this
minkovski in 1905 gamma should increase
as n over 2 pi e the 2 pi e is coming
back so if you go back to to 1905
minkovski there exists dense lattices
you the gamma is going to be as n over 2
pi e and then the max found by a gabber
chance k and Levenstein in 1979 you get
one point seven four four divided by two
pi e n so these are the best lattices
for packing but again i don't care about
the packing I want to reach the Sigma
max Pulte rev limit and you will see
that I don't need n log n here is enough
to reach the Sigma max okay so so
remember that R is K over N again and K
is the dimension of the code and n is
the length of the code inside the code
within the construction a of our lattice
okay so I will give an interpretation of
this bound but before that I need this
lemma for for my for my theorem so this
is well known as the sphere hardening in
high dimensions the volume is the volume
of your ball is around this is around
the sphere it's not in the in the middle
of the ball so here you take n iid
Gaussian and zero Sigma square in fact
this is our noise or it's the same as
could have put theta here and then the
probability to be between Sigma square
root of N 1 minus epsilon and Sigma
square root of N 1 is 1 so it means in
hi dimension the Gaussian noise is going
to be like this well almost is here this
is in high dimension the proof is very
simple chebychev we're not asking about
very fast convergence here it's it's
it's just 1 log n in square but that's
enough to prove that we have this fear
hardening effect in high dimensions yes
actually I'm confused by the meaning of
decoding probability it's just a fact
that you take a Gaussian noise and what
is the probability that this Gaussian
noise stays within the Voronoi cell of
the lattice yes this is yeah exactly so
if I go back this is the probability of
error per point it's the probability of
X different from X hat so X hat is what
the decoder
let's stay close this point decoder so
when you go outside the Voronoi regions
indeed you get in error now I'm going to
deal with this without knowing the shape
of my Voronoi cell because our lattice
family will be random how by using this
ball the ball of the noise okay so let
me go back to this so what are we saying
here is that the noise is behaving like
this in high dimensions so I have a
noise noise this figure if you want and
I'm going to put this sphere around Y
around the noisy point and then if I
have two lattices to put two points two
lattice points inside this sphere then I
just fear it means I may have a mistake
if I have a unique lattice point then
I'm good I'm decoding well you see what
I mean I don't need to know the shape of
the Voronoi cell just I'm using the so
the noise ball I'm going to call it the
decoding ball why because I know that my
noise is not going to go more than this
sphere so why do we need to know the
shape of different
need to know the shape of those so you
receive who I remember my notation what
is why okay I'm sorry for maybe I should
have put this any simplest why is the
noisy version of the lattice point okay
and again I'm dealing with the infinite
lattice to simplify what do you think if
I transmit zero here does it change the
probability of error question is this
probability of error depends on the
transmitted lattice point X no because
it's a lattice you stand up on any
lattice point you look around you you
have the same landscape so in fact for
simplicity let's say X is zero and what
is y finally y is the noise itself okay
so now you have a noise around the
origin you will not go beyond the noise
ball I'm talking about and the the
radius is Sigma square root of N and
then all you need to do is to check
inside the noise ball if you have
another lattice point or not if you have
another lattice point then there is a
mistake if if 0 is the unique lattice
point and the noise ball there is no
error ok I will write it down later so
remember that in high dimension we have
this sphere hardening phenomena
okay I'm transmitting zero I have a
noise and this is why okay so I know
what do I do I do a and now let me put
the noise around why they dip the ball
around why yes so this is B Y in
dimension N and radius is wrong draw it
better than this and here I have Rho
okay imagine this is I'm not I'm not
using the Euclidean metric okay since
this is the Boutros metric and I'm sorry
so so so you have the the decoding ball
around around Y okay so you don't need
twice this now of course if I have
another lattice point here let's say X
belonging to two lambda then it doesn't
mean there is a mistake why because it's
like this decoding now your decoder is
supposed to choose is it zero or is it X
but again it gives you an upper bound of
the probability of error I will write it
down later okay thankfully so no but I
will use this fear hardening just to
give you a geometrical interpretation of
Polti Rev okay so so this is a nice very
nice Bora noisette of course in high
dimensions we don't know about this but
probably if the lattice is good enough
you will have almost spherical shape
okay so you know about the first radius
the packing radius and the second one
the bigger one the covering radius now
I'm going to use I think you talked
about it when you talk the effective
radius so so what is the effective
radius it's the radius of a sphere with
the same volume as the Voronoi cell
volume okay now why because in fact the
effective radius is related to polti Rev
so you start with a small noise more
noise
well why I'm drawing the noise as this
field because again
member the noises is almost is almost at
a radius of Sigma square root of n Sigma
square root of n ok so small noise more
noise and pop now you reach the limit so
when the noise noise reaches the
effective radius you are at the limit
and now what is funny if you write the
the volume of the noise ball equal to
two the volume of the Voronoi cell you
get the 1 over 2 pi e you get polti rev
limit because they are equal in this
case okay now another lemma sorry I need
two more lemmas before the theorem this
is how to count I think also we talked
about this in the first day or the
second day of this workshop I have a
ball centered on C in dimension n with
radius Rho how many integer points
inside inside this board we have a nice
upper bound it includes
Rho of course and n now how do I get
this upper bound it's not complicated I
didn't I want it to make a picture but I
have already enough pictures in on my
slides you take a cube let me call it C
said of volume 1 and you put a cube of
volume 1 around each integer point okay
how much is the diagonal of this cube
square root of n so when you put cubes
around all these points you will not go
outside more than square root of n over
2 so in fact if you take a ball of of
the same radius Rho and you add half of
the diagonal you're going to include all
the cubes all the cubes around these
integer points in be fine done then then
the number of points is upper bounded by
the same ball but you increase the
radius by square root of n over 2 and
then you put this outside done now what
do we do is this with this volume
stealing stealing formula you get this
approximation yes
the covering radius of Zn yeah indeed
yeah nd it's just it's very simple yeah
okay now here just we put also stabling
we put them together yeah we got this
ugly formula but that's fine the formula
is here why because I need to plug it
again in my upper bound later in the
film and then a lot of algebraic
manipulations before finding that it's
going to vanish okay
any other question it's not tight but
it's enough it's enough for what we're
doing it's more important is the effect
of P I'll show you later in the bound
the effect of P okay now one more lemma
I'm sorry again
now in this lemma I'm in fact what I'm
telling you I'm telling you the
following if I have a point here which
is let's say p 0 0 0 so one of the
components is multiple of P the point is
not going to be in this decoding book
it's going to be outside so what is this
this is this is the distance between
1808 a - 0 greater than the distance
between AP and Z and this Zed has
multiples of P so this is the design I'm
talking about outside in fact it's known
to be outside why because the
probability of this is going to vanish
now the proof is not very complicated
how do I do the proof being far away
from that means one of the component in
fact is greater than P of you to think
about it like this this is 0 I'm taking
only one dimension and this is this
point but in one dimension and then this
is P and then I need just to cross P
over 2 I need to cross P over 2 in one
direction now what I'm going to do I'm
so in one direction then I'm going to
upper bound by
in all directions and times this
probability and this probability is
twice the Gaussian tale function sorry
a times is this the noise it is in fact
this is aekta
y is going to be 0 plus theta this is
the Sigma ok so eta is a 2 1 a 2 n in RN
and again and at the I is n 0 Sigma
square ok which Sigma I'm using this
Sigma Y because I want to be as close as
possible to pull t rev limit to see
what's happening at multi Rev limits so
I'm taking Sigma square equals Sigma X 1
minus Delta square right now I'm putting
the Delta but later I need to I need to
prove the theorem for any Delta that's
fine
a delta positive so so again imagine
this is the 0 let me let me show it here
now this is 0 this is P over 2 this is P
over 2
ok and then what do you have here you
have a Gaussian noise n 0 Sigma square
ok what is the probability of the
Gaussian noise call it Etta one the one
belonging outside C over 2 minus P over
2 plus P over
how much is this this is twice Q P over
2
obviously here is the caption page
function okay now this is just in one
dimension the problem is I don't know
how many components are exceeding P over
two in absolute value then what do I do
I upper bound by n + x 2q sorry I wrote
it like this to end but it's n times
okay then then again I'm not using a
very very complicated upper bound for Qi
upper bound q by E minus X 2 over 2 this
is a well-known upper bound for the
Gaussian theta function and you get this
now it's enough to choose P log n some
power of log n you plug it there there
is a conditioned on a on the exponent it
should be greater than 1 over to R and
then this will vanish this will vanish
why this ulema is important it means we
get rid of all points integer points
which are which are multiple of P and
which have components multiple of P
where they are they are outside this
noise board and now why because later
I'm going to enumerate all integer
points inside this noise board and check
if I have a lattice point if I have
known at this point here inside it means
my error probability is vanishing fine
I'm happy this is so so I'm imagining
that I make my closest lattice point
decoder is using this this noise board
this decoding boy the radius of the
decoding ball is Sigma square root of n
times 1 plus Epsilon because I'm going
to take the upper bound times d1 minus
Delta
this is this is a virtual this is the
best decoder we have across this point
decoder I'm not saying that this is what
I'm going to implement in practice this
is a decoder working on the error
probity per point and as I told decrease
that why I'm dealing later with ser
because in my demo I will show you a
decoder working in dimension 1 million
but in dimension 1 million I'm not going
to do closest point decoder I'm going to
do iterative decoding it's a local
decoder which works on each lattice
coordinate and then I each rate over the
lattice coordinate about 40 times to
reach zero in dimension 1 million okay
now these are just simple bounds which
I'm going to block later this is a
well-known bound for very large n when n
goes to infinity the binomial
coefficient behaves like exponential in
n with the entropy function probably you
know this bound of course yeah this is a
nice bound so we have a behavior like 2
and aah of theta where H is the binary
function in your H of theta and we have
also if n is small in fact this is going
to be the N 0 the code inside the
lattice we can use this for small n we
have three possibilities which one is
the best we use the best of ok so I
think now you have we have almost
everything ready to prove the theorem
but what lattice I'm going to build
that's the question and I need to build
Lda lattices or GLD lattices so first
let me explain what is quickly what is
in LDPC code so you all know about
Hamming codes it's not important to be
Hamming or not let's say this is a 7 4
code and this is the generator matrix of
the code so it means the rows here are
the bases of the code as a subspace of F
2 2 7 this is the binary and what is H
ace is the generator matrix of the null
space of the dual code dimension n minus
K now for this small code
I'm not you're going to use n and k I
should have put here n 0 k 0 for this
more code right now if you look at H you
know that any code word multiplied by H
transpose should be 0 so this is the
syndrome the 0 Center ok now I'm going
to build a graph out of H graph
representation it's really a powerful
representation because it lets you see
really how you do the analysis of the
code see how the code is behaving the
cycles in the graph and also do
iterative decoding over this graph so
this is called a Tanner graph this was
proposed by Michael Connor in 1981 but
he also proposed other other codes
structures I mean graphs so this is the
standard one what do you do on one side
you put the 7 coordinates of a code word
so the 7 coordinates here are associated
to the 7 columns of H and then on the
other side you put the rows of H ok let
me look for example at the first row the
first row involves the first column the
third column the fourth and the fifth
the first row involves the first column
the third the fourth and the fifth ok so
it means what in practice it means that
the 7 bits here these are binary digits
now the 7 bits are a code word if and
only if C 1 plus C 3 plus C 4 plus C 5
equal to 0 and C 2 plus C 1 plus C 2
plus C 3 plus 6 equal to 0 and so in
fact you we call these check nodes why
check nodes because the sum of the bits
here should be 0 to have the coder okay
how do we call these vertices here we
call them bit nodes now I'm not going to
deal with the binary code so I'm going
to deal with P P increasing with n then
are we going to call them variable nodes
so variable nodes on this side and check
nodes on the other sides
now while I'm talking about this this is
the graph representation Tanner graph of
an LDPC code sorry of this code now how
do I build an LDPC code you let the
graph you take infinite number of
vertices on both sides the ratio should
be constant and then however you fix the
degree of the vertices is finite you get
a low-density graph why because the
number of edges is going to be linear in
n not in n square okay again if you go
back here if I have a dense matrix H
this will behave the number of ones will
be as N squared so I'm going to take a
sparse matrix H this is what we call an
LDPC code and this is the first family
of lattices in LD a lattice is when see
the code see used in the construction a
is an LDPC code so remember this is what
I said LDPC code is defined by a sparse
parity check matrix you let n go to
infinity and H is sparse and you plug
the LDPC code here in the construction a
and this is what I call LD a lattice yld
a low-density construction any lattice
what is low-density is not the lattice
itself is the code inside the lattice
okay now many people work on these
lattices the work started almost like
let's say 2011 with with sparse codes if
you check this paper appeared in 2018 in
the transaction information theory you
will see all the proofs there but it's a
very long table very tedious so we have
the proof for infinite and for finite
constellations both of them polti Rev is
reached using Lda lattices and channel
capacity channel capacity is when you
take a finite number of points in the
lattice but today I'm talking only I'm
dealing only with multi Africans i'm
talking about infinite consumption now
the other family of lattice is GLD this
is little bit tricky you take lambda 0
and you take a direct sum L times of
lambda 0 and then intersection of many
directions
with permutations so this is the GLD
lattice now the simple case let me take
the simple case with construction a you
take a code C 0 L times direct sum and
then you make random permutations of the
coordinates and intersection of J bar
Exams now to direct sums is enough so
these are called GL d calls and then
when you put the GLD code inside
construction a you get also GL d lattice
okay again we have the proof that we
reach multi rev limit and as I said it's
slightly better because we are not
dealing with finite constellation that's
why P is better P is increasing as log N
and set as n probably if we if we put
here the finite constellations I think
the log n will not hold anymore okay and
this is again in a paper appeared in
August 2019 in the information theory
workshop in Sweden now let me show you
the example just simple example of two
intersections so you take c0 direct some
L times to imagine this is c0 direct
some L times okay in my pictures and L
is only 2 and then you take in another
direct form of C 0 this is the ID at the
second direction so I have two
directions of c0 now I'm going to do
intersection what does V intersection it
means the coordinates of the codeword
with all you see here they are all
connected to the first direct sum what
type of permutations here just take
identity it's enough no need to do any
permutation for the first one so here
I'm you see I'm not putting any
permutation here no need this is this is
very important
permuting the second direct Sun so this
is the direct Sun the second direct sam
and where is the second permutation it's
the matching the edge matching so the
matching of edges from the left to the
right is given by the permutation pi you
understand this graph please so this
graph this Tanner graph represent the
intersection of two direct thumbs after
permuting the second direct song this is
the permutation and this is the identity
the time no yes it's just the code the
parity check matrix of the Tanner graph
of the code itself and the bottom one
this is the same thing except the the
coordinates of the code the left thing
the let nodes are permuted ism hmm yes
okay okay let me give you a simpler
explanation
now imagine forget the two rows take
only the first row
what is the first row it's a simple
parity check code what is the second row
another parity check code what is the
third row a third parity check code fine
what does it mean you belong to to the
code it means the three of them should
be satisfied so you are belonging to the
intersection of these three codes so
what you're doing here in fact this is
the intersection of the sample code and
the sample code the sample this is true
for any code in fact now what I'm doing
it's more complicated what I'm doing
here I'm taking not only c0 I'm taking
the many C zeros okay and then and then
the per muted version of these many see
zeros the direct sum so what does it
mean I have two edges per variable
it means this variable belongs to this
check node and this variable belongs to
this check node and of course here the
Sunda parity should be satisfied the sum
of if this is binary the sum of bits
should be zero but here we're not in the
binary case here we have a sum with non
binary coefficients equal to zero the
check node D the parity check equation
is not binary anymore it's non binary is
it fine for this graph now what I'm
going to do it's very tricky because the
I have only here a degree tool so
imagine I'm going to take these checks
put them on the Left take the circles
you see I take this edge and the second
edge and replace this by unique edge
where are the circles the circles will
disappear the circles are here in the
middle
okay so this is the second time I run is
it fine you take this you put them on
the left now you will have just edges
coming from you will have the check node
on the left the check node on the right
and then the variable node is in the
middle like this now take it out it's
fine just put in edge and now where are
the variable nodes no more variable
nodes we have variables on the edges I
have the code lengths is n I have n
edges first thing I do is I take the
parity check matrix and I create a Dyke
block diagonal matrix that's the parity
check matrix of the so the you know
concatenated code and then I take the
purview the columns of this thing yes
then I put one on top of the other
that's it right row so this is exactly H
0 H 0 H 0 H 0 so this is the upper half
of my bigger parity check matrix and
then what do you do in the lower half
you permute the columns you put them
down this is exactly one Bravo this is
exactly what we're doing
yeah but why I'm showing the this graph
because it's much better to work on this
graph on the right hand right no it's
the same it's the same this is the same
as oh look there's one edge like this I
draw it like this and the circle is in
and I take out the circle so the
variable nodes are here are on the edges
why because now I only deal with check
nodes where are the four heroes they are
on the edges yeah so this is very
special
these graphs do not exist in standard
LDPC codes these graphs exist on
in GLD codes there are no variable nodes
anymore no circles only squares
representing check nodes so now where
are the variables there on the edges
it's the same graph exactly the same
graph not building another is it fine
crease again what I said
you take these squares put them on the
left how many squares you have L Big L
squares on the left and these are the
squares on the right and then you have
only one edge going like this only one
edge so you get this and now all the
analysis is made is made on this graph
everything is on this graph can we think
of there being yes yeah now imagine you
have a complete graph complete guess
what do you see the code if it is
complete the graph product code
this is a product code if I put a
completely graph here now but of course
I don't want to make it but I want a
low-density graph I'm not going to me if
you okay think about it later I will
show you after the talk if you put a
complete graph here you get the product
code so it means what I'm doing I'm
taking a low-density version of out of a
product code I'm getting aglt good and
I'm letting n go to infinity
I'll show it's very simple to do so
believe me write it down if the code is
if the if it is a complete graph you get
the product okay now let me show you
quickly the proof we don't have a lot of
time the proof the proof of the theorem
that these GLD lattices achieve polity
of capacity portalab limit so we can let
the error probability vanish for any
Sigma square less than Sigma max I need
a delta I need a code which we call
asymptotically good code means the
Hamming distance of the code should
increase as Delta n Delta strictly
positive and then we have a small
constraint on a but the constraint comes
from the lemma on the points with
multiples of P that's fine okay so I
think if you understand just the first
page the rest are just algebraic
calculations okay just understand here
in the first place and this is what we
talked about already using the noise so
I have lattice symmetry I can assume
that Y is zero plus eight okay so lambda
admits the closest point decoder so this
is not a decoder that's going to run to
run here on my clinics in front of you I
hope in in two minutes okay
not sure if I can finish this in two
minutes but ultra the the radius of the
noise ball I also call it the decoding
ball Sigma square root of M I take the
upper bound one word plus epsilon and I
replace Sigma by the Polti rev limit
times 1 minus Delta okay so I get this
now let's say this is Kappa and then the
rest is here I need to plug this in all
formulas draw okay
so the decoding ball will be byn row
centered on y with radius row now how
can we upper bound the profit of error
is understand this this is very
important bullet let LF be the number of
nonzero lattice point in in B so this is
what I said nonzero lattice points if if
Aleph greater than or equal to 1 what
does it mean
I have other lattice points here inside
the ball okay now of course why this is
not inequality why this is an upper
bound because the decoder may decide to
choose 0 and then there is no error
despite the presence of another lattice
point in the ball why not
so that's why this is a Napper bar okay
so the probability of L if greater than
1 is this is an upper bound of P now and
of course you can upper bound this by
because this is an integer random
variable by the expectation of Aleph and
then how do I find the expectation of
Aleph you write it as the sum of
indicator function where inside the ball
for integer points inside the ball you
apply the expectation and then I get
what PE is upper bounded by the sum of
all integer points inside the decoding
boil some of what probability that this
integer point belongs to lambda so now
what do we have here I have an integer
of n coordinates in the space and this
integers inside the ball lambda is
random Y lambda is random because the
permutation pi inside the JLT code is
random and I can assume that the code C
0 divided by H 0 is random then lambda
is random what is the probability that X
belongs to lambda and that's it this is
what we want to go to to find now
probability of X belonging to lambda
later I'm going to write it very quickly
let me show you sorry here
here this part probability of X
belonging to lambda is the probability
that X belongs to all modulo P of course
to all direct sums
how many dollar it sounds I'm
intersecting J direct Sam's you can look
at this okay so let me go back I'm here
so I I put them together so PE is upper
bounded by some I didn't want to start
directly by this but this is also
obvious the sum or all X belonging to
that n intersection with B and then now
what do I do
I don't know how to sum over X's inside
the ball these are deterministic points
so what do we do
we introduce the Hamming weight L now we
sum over L we know that L starts from
Delta and this is asymptotically good
code up to n and then here we have the
weight of X is fixed now why is
interesting to know that the weight of X
is fixed if you look at this sum here
what do you have we know how many points
we have in this board yeah we know the
number of points but now we are fixing
the Hamming weight to L what does it
mean now you are going to dimension L so
now the ball is in dimension L and then
you use my ulema on counting points in
dimension L not in dimension n you go
down to a smaller dimension which is L
so this is going to appear later in the
next slide and then I replace this px
belong to lambda and now the problem is
here here I have a step I don't have
time to show it so this is the miracle
in my theorem I'm going to use something
called buckets bucketz approach so this
is the some buckets approach given the
time I can see the time there what do we
do in the bucket please look at the
paper of August 2019
I'll use the saddle point approach to
solve this problem in fact we worked
together in Qatar with node Amir and my
arable off we found a way to find this
probability of B it will be an upper
bound so if you want to talk about it I
have all the afternoon no problem after
ste p.m. so we plug the probability here
at the end all calculations done we get
a big formula
as here l is going to go to infinity
like n and here inside we have a big
function and the only thing you need to
prove that this function is less than 1
now what I use to get this formula we
used all the lambda we saw before all
together all the equations and this
explains also the we used also the
binomial coefficient upper bound that's
why you have h here appearing lower
bound also you have H down so so you get
big calculations I'm not showing these
steps and then you prove that this is
less than 1 so when L go to infinity
this will go to 0 let me show you the
same lattice GLD lattice J equal to 2
intersection of two directions and 0 is
only 3 and this is in dimension 1
million and I'm going to go at point 5
DB the Sybil from Polti rev limit so
this is what I'm in fact I'm the curve
is here but I will show you one point
this is dimensioned one thousand ten
thousand one hundred thousand 1 million
and what happened at dimension 1 million
we are 0.3 decibel if you convert to
real this is 93 percent of Sigma max
square Sigma square is 93% oh now you
may say ok is it really very good zero
zero point 3 DB this is almost the
unbreakable limit up to now where is the
leech lattice if you take 24 delish
lattice is at 40 seabed it's there so
standard lattices are there if we take
also low density lattices they are may
be around 1 DB so G LD and LD a we where
only the unique lattice is going so
close to 2 pole T rev limit okay in in
in smaller dimensions you have this this
is the sample error rate this is the
word error rate the point error rate
error rate per lattice coordinate error
rate per point this is compared small
dimensions one thousand ten thousand
this is LD a and notice there is no
error
or behavior here because the interleaver
the permutation is optimized here I
didn't do any permutation optimization
so why we have this behavior because we
have a Poisson distribution of cycles
and the Poisson distribution of cycles
gives you 1 over N what does mean 1 over
N if I multiply by 10 I go down by 10
every time okay so the demo this is 1
million this is dimension ok sorry
1 million minus 1 why because I need to
be multiple of 2 or multiple of 3 ok so
this is and then the dimension is 2 of
the small code P is 11 it's not a very
big deal
so and then we decode so now each time
you see a line 1 line it means one line
means we went over 6 to L 2 L check
nodes
how much is L you saw the number here L
is 300,000 3 3 so we are doing 600,000
the check nodes in each line 600,000
check nodes it's running on my CPU here
let me prove it
top so it's running on this machine
100% of one CPU only 1.5 gig of ram it's
fine it's not n square it's over n and
then what you see here the probity of
error per lattice coordinate 500000
lettuce coordinates erroneous it means
at the channel output have more than
half of the lattice coordinates are
erroneous doing ground to nearest
integer it will not work okay
then with the iteration what's happening
after 24 iterations only 15,000 ok it's
been what 1 minute it will take 40
iterations look it's going down we reach
0 after 40 tuition
1 5 3 3 10 2 minus 3 10 to minus 4 and
then it goes down very quickly now at
the end sometimes it can it can stay
stuck in to lattice coordinates why
because we have a cycle a butterfly
cycle in the graph if the graph is not
optimized 48 15 15 coordinates out of 1
million so that's why 10 2 minus 6 it
stuck at 1 1 1 it trying to now 0 0 it's
over okay so after 40 iterations we all
the errors were corrected so the
conclusions I told you about 1 over 2 pi
e I showed that glt lattices using a
reasonable value for P we can actually
achieve the poly rev limit the
complexity while the complexity is like
this I have time to tell you it's linear
in n but the P can be if you increase n
0 minus K 0 this can be difficult to
decode in practice now the the questions
that you should answer the audience
should answer applications in
cryptography
[Applause]
this if you go to peas which is
polynomial mm you gain anything you
don't get input your EV because you
already have 40 Rev you probably gain in
the reshaping so it means one I take
yeah so the Voronoi why because think
about it we said what the code is doing
is helping the lattice around the origin
this comes from from this lemma okay you
have the point the points to be excluded
okay so this this llama means the the
the code is good the lattice is good
around the origin now what's happening
if you go a little bit further you have
the faces of the Voronoi region no
control on these faces because also P is
small so probably if we do shaping if we
try to be shaping maybe we will not be
able to do 1 over 2 pi e in the shaping
I don't know right now I don't have the
answer
so maybe the value of PE which is
increasing in log and and set of n will
make the covering we call this covering
goodness covering goodness will not be
achievable so again this is still an
open question we didn't solve it yet
any question this where the codes that
you're taking the direct sum and in
practice like when you're applying the
construction the base but one which is
running in practice so III did the
following huh so I guess it's very
simple I I think I took C zero is very
simple code three to over 11 so this is
a parity check code then I did Gallagher
equation construction so I did C zero
direct sum with C 0 how many times the
in the demo you saw is three 303 and
thirty three hundred thousand okay times
three you get nine nine nine nine nine
you get 1 million minus one and then
this is intersection with a per muted
version of the same direction so so
that's why in in the demo each time we
see one error probability displayed it
means we decode here and we decode here
we are decoding 600 600,000 check nodes
at each iteration corresponding to 1
million letters coordinates and 48
iterations so so in the demo how many
lattice point we decoded what so I
showed you the decoding of one lattice
point but this was in dimension 1
million it takes two minutes and
dimension 1 million to decode one
lattice point
thank you
[Applause]